Deniz Hoca kanalına Hoşgeldiniz gençler
Selamlar sevgiler 9 sınıf edebiyat ders
çalışmamız devam ediyor ve bu videoda
biyografi otobiyografi tezkireyi tamamen
bitireceğiz en önemli noktaları bilmeniz
gereken her şey bu videoda sizlere
aktaracağım tek bir video ile artık
biyografi ünitesini geçebileceksiniz
Hazırsanız 3 2 1 Haydi bakalım
başlıyorum öyle fazla konuşmayacağım bu
sefer net konuşacağım derslere geçeceğiz
ilk konumuz biyografi olacak sonra
otobiyografi sonra da tezkireyi sizlere
aktaracağım Hazır mısın Öyleyse
biyografi gelsin nedir oldukça kolay
sanat edebiyat bilim siyaset sinema gibi
alanlarda ün yapmış okuyucuların
ilgisini çekebilecek kişilerin
hayatların Tarafsız bir şekilde ele
alındığı Metin türüne Biz biyografi
diyoruz Yani özetle şudur tanınmış bir
kişinin hayatı öyküsünü anlatan
metinlere biyografi denir ama bu
kişilerin tanınmış kişiler olması
gerekiyor Yoksa seni kim okusun kim
merak etsin değil mi merak ettiğimiz
birinin hayatını okumak isteriz aynı
zamanda bir yaşam öyküsü olarak da
adlandırılan biyografilerin asıl amacı
tecrübelerin okuyacağı aktarılmasıdır
Yani evet birinin hayatını merak
edersiniz ama daha çok şunun içinde
okumak istersiniz Acaba nasıl başarmış
acaba nasıl bir yaşam öyküsü var Hangi
zorluklardan geçmiş Neyi doğru yaptı ki
başarıya ulaştı İşte bu merak duygusu
bizi okumaya sevk edendir diyorum ve
devam ediyoruz biyografiler sanat
siyaset bilim çeşitli alanlarda bir
belge niteliği taşımaktadır yani
Düşünsenize 100 yıl önce yaşamış bir
şeyleri başarmış birisinin hayatını
okurken Aslında Siz 100 yıl öncesine bir
ziyaret etmiş olursunuz yazıyor öncesine
gitmiş olursunuz o dönemi görmüş
olursunuz Bu bakımdan biyografiler bir
belge niteliği kazanır diyebiliriz ve
biyografideki kişi anlatılırken yazar
tarafsız olmak zorunda yani tarafsız
olacak durum Neyse bunu aktarmak
durumunda öyle kişisel düşünceleri
yorumlara yer vermez Dolayısıyla
özellikle altını kez daha çiziyorum
kişisel düşüncelere ve yorumlara yer
verilmez biyografide ve devam ediyoruz
biyografi eseri bir plan çerçevesinde
kişinin doğum çocukluk gençlik yaşlılık
öğrenim meslek gibi hayat serüveni ele
alır yani bir kronolojik sıra izlenir
Aslında doğumu çocukluğu lise hayatı
üniversite hayatı evlilik hayatı iş
hayatı ve ömrünün sonundaki O kısım
artık neyse bunlar sırasıyla
biyografilerde karşımıza çıkmaktadır
Tabi bir biyografi eseri yazmadan önce
ne yapmamız gerekiyor
Sırma içerisinde girmemiz gerekiyor Yani
o biyografideki hakkında detaylı bir
araştırma yapar yazar belge ve
elde ettiği bilgileri olduğu gibi
aktarır Bu arada bu araştırma sırasında
o kişinin yakınlarıyla da görüşür hatta
yaşıyorsa o kişi o kişiyle de
görüşülebilir ondan daha net bilgiler
alınabilir ama daha çok bir Kişi
öldükten sonra onun biyografisi yazılır
o zaman yakınlarına başvururuz onu
tanıyan onunla vakit geçirmiş kişilerden
de fazlasıyla yararlanılır diyoruz
biyografilerde Açık ve anlaşılır bir dil
kullanılmalıdır Çünkü amacın okuyacağı
ulaşmak okuyacağı bilgi vermek Belki de
tecrübelerini aktarmak o kişinin
Dolayısıyla dilinin de açık anlaşılır
olması gerekiyor yani romandaki
hikayedeki ya da şehirdeki o mecazlı
anlatım biyografilerde karşımıza çıkmaz
az önce de vurgulamıştım biyografiler
Sıradan insanlar için yazılmaz okuyucu
tarafından okunabilecek ilgi
duyulabilecek kişilerin biyografisi
yazılabilir diyoruz ve eski
edebiyatımızda bu biyografiye tercümayı
hal ismi de verilmiştir yani tercümayı
hal ismi karşına çıkarsa bunun biyografi
olduğunu unutmuyorsun güzel öğrencim
yine biraz eskilere gideceğiz yani Divan
edebiyatına gideceğiz biliyorsunuz bizim
yaklaşık 600 yıllık bir edebiyat
geleneğimizdir Divan edebiyat
ı ismine ismi tezkire tezkireler de
aynen Biyografi gibi sanatçıların yaşam
öyküsünü bizlere aktarır ancak tezkere
birazdan deneyeceğim biraz daha sabır
birazdan detaylı bir şekilde sizlere
aktaracağım bazen de bir kişinin
hayatının yola çıkılarak bir roman
yazılabilir yani birisinin hayatını Biz
Roman olarak da paylaşabiliriz bu
tarzdaki Romanlara biyografik Roman
denir Bak bunun en ünlü örneği Oğuz
Atay'ın yazmış olduğu bir bilim adamının
romanıdır Bu bir bilim adamının romanı
adlı eserinde Oğuz Atay üniversiteden
hocası olan Mustafa inanın anlatmışlar
Yani aslında bu Roman bir biyografidir
Dolayısıyla biz buna ne diyoruz
biyografi diyoruz hem biyografi hem de
biraz böyle işin içerisinde kurguda
kalktığı için buna biyografi Roman
diyoruz bunlarda yine aklımızda bulunsun
Bu yine biraz geriye gitmiş şöyle öne
doğru çekeyim Hah böyle daha gençler
dünyada biyografi denildiği zaman akla
gelen bir isim vardır Onu da hemen şöyle
çizelim pult tarkos pult tarkos
dünyadaki en meşhur biyografi yazarıdır
aklımıza bulunsun sınavda öğretmenimiz
sorabilir diyorum ve 16 yüzyıla
geldiğimiz zaman Avrupa'da biyografi
türünde bir gelişme meydana geliyor Yani
biyografiye bir tür olarak bakılıyor ve
biyografiye Özen gösteriliyor Ondan
sonra biyografi daha farklı bir şekilde
gelişiyor Bizde ise biyografi türünün
ilk örneklerine az önce de vurgulamıştım
tezkirelerde rastlıyoruz Divan
edebiyatında ama birazdan buna
değineceğiz diyorum ve bizim
edebiyatımızdaki ilk tezkire örneği de
Ali Şir Nevai'nin yazmış olduğu
mecâlüsün ne faizdir hemen şöyle
yuvarlak içerisinde alayım Ama detaya
inmeyeceğim Çünkü dediğim gibi birkaç
kez tekrar ettim birazdan deneyeceğiz
tespihlere Türk edebiyatında tanımış
bazı biyografi eserlerine de şöyle liste
halinde göz atalım Mehmet Kaplan'ın
Namık Kemal'in hayatı ve eserleri adlı
bir eseri vardır Bu önemli bir biyografi
eseridir Bunun dışında kenara akyüzüm
Tevfik Fikret'i Şevket Süreyya
Aydemir'in tek Süleyman nazif'in Mehmet
Akif'i Yakup Kadir Karaosmanoğlu'nun
Atatürk'ü Asım bezircinin Orhan velisi
ünlü meşhur biyografi eserlerin başında
gelmektedir kitabımızda da bu eserler
yer alıyor Bu nedenle sınavda çıkabilir
diye şöyle Aşina olmanız sizler için
faydalı olacaktır diyorum ve Nereye
geliyoruz Evet otobiyografiye geldik
biyografi neydi başkasının Hayat
öyküsünü anlatan bir metin türüydü
otobiyografi ise kişinin öz yaşam
öyküsüdür hemen tanıma bakalım öz yaşam
öyküsü olarak da bilinen otobiyografi
belli bir alanda üne kavuşmuş bireyin
kendi yaşamından önemlidir ve ilginç
yönlerini ayrıntılı bir şekilde
anlattığı bir metin türüdür yani Ben
başkasını hayatını yazarsam bu biyografi
olur kendi yaşamımı yazarsam Bu da
otobiyografi olur edebiyat sanat siyaset
spor gibi değişik alanlarda ünlü bir
kişi diğer insanlarca bilinmeyen
yönlerini başarısını ne borçlu olduğunu
ve nasıl o kazandığını anlatmak amacıyla
bir otobiyografi yazabilir Yani neden
bir insan otobiyografi yazar neden bir
insan kendi yaşam öyküsünü Anlatmak
ister gençlere gelecek nesile bazı
nasihatlar da bulunmak için yani onun
başarısına gıpta eden gençlere ben
şunları şunları şunları yaptım ki bu
noktaya ulaştım şekilde bir mesaj verir
yazar bu eser üzerinden otobiyografide
yazar hayatının önemli kesitlerini ilgi
çekici yönlerini ve Başarılarını yani
Anlatmaya değer gördüğün ne varsa
bunları otobiyografisinde bizlere
detaylı bir şekilde aktarabilir
biyografiler nesneldir diyoruz
arkadaşlar Neden Çünkü ben başkasının
Hayat öyküsünü yazıyorum mesela Ahmet'in
yaşam öyküsünü yazıyorum ya onun iyi
yönlerini anlattığım gibi kötü yönlerini
de anlatabilirim Çünkü bunu bana bir
zararı Yok ben tarafsız bir şekilde Neyi
görüyorsam neye ulaştıysam bunu
aktarırım O yüzden biyografiler bakma
nesneldir ancak otobiyografilerde aynı
şeyi söyleyemiyoruz Neden Çünkü ben
kendi yaşamıma hükmü anlatıyorum sizce
Uyumsuz gördüm başkaları tarafından
eleştirilebilecek kınanabilecek
özelliklerimi ya da davranışlarımı ya da
öykümü aktarabilir miyim aktarmam ister
istemez bunu yapamam zaten bu yüzden
unutmuyorsun biyografiler nesnel
otobiyografiler ise özneldir karşımıza
bir karşılaştırma olarak çıkarsa ilk
başta bunu yazmanı senden bekliyor Az
önce birinin yaşam öyküsünü Roman olarak
yazarsak buna biyografik Roman denir
demiştim aynı şeyi bir yazar kendi
hayatından çıkarak da yapabilir yani
kendi hayatını romanlaştırabilir bu
tarzdaki Romanlara Biz otobiyografik
Roman diyoruz bak örnek olarak da
Safa'nın 9 Hariciye Koğuşu Hemen aklına
gelsin oldukça meşhur bir romandır Belki
de sen zaten bu romanı okudu bu romanda
Peyami Safa kendi çocukluk anılarından
çıkarak bir şeyler aktarır hasta bir
çocuğa aktarır onun Aşk hayatına aktarır
vesaire Aslında o kendi çocukluk
öyküsüdür Dolayısıyla biz buna ne
diyoruz psikolojik roman Ama bunun
yanında otobiyografi
diyoruz Bunun dışında Orhan Kemal'in
Baba evi ve Avare yıllar adlı eserleri
de otobiyografik romana örnek olarak
gösterilebilir bu eserleri de
unutmuyoruz Çünkü karşımıza sınavda
çıkma ihtimali çok yüksek ve geliyoruz
otobiyografinin Türk Edebiyatındaki
önemli temsilcilerine iki tane isim
hemen dikkatimizi çekiyor Bu ikisini
asla unutmayacaksın bir tanesi Abidin
Dino bir tanesi de Şevket Süreyya
Aydemir Abidin dino'nun kısa Hayat hüküm
adlı bir eseri var dediğim gibi
otobiyografik alanında önemlidir
meşhurdur yine Şevket Süreya'nın suyu
arayan adam adlı eserde bu türde
tanınmış meşhur bir eserdir asla ama
asla unutma o Tabii biyografiden
bahsetmişken burada 4 farklı terime daha
değineceğim bunlar Monografi özgeçmişi
bir hal tercümesi ve portre şimdi
bunları yakından görelim Öncelikle
özgeçmişten yani cv'den başlayalım
biliyorsunuz bir yere başvuruda
Bulunduğunuz zaman iş başvurusunda
sizden bir CV isterler O cv'de ne
yaparsınız
kendi okul hayatınızı çalışma hayatınızı
kurs geçmişinizi tecrübelerinizi
deneyimlerinizi paylaşırsınız bunları
bir rapor haline getirirsiniz İşte biz
buna özgeçmiş İngilizce'de ise şöyle bir
ifade kullanırız bunu da kısaltması gibi
gençler gelelim monografiye Monografi
ünlü birine ait bir konuyu eseri
herhangi bir durumu derinlemesine ele
alıp inceleyen eserlerdir biyografiden
farklı olarak burada belli bir noktaya
odaklanırsın ve onu daha detaylı bir
şekilde inceleyip okuyucuya aktarılsın
Bu da Monografi oluyordu Peki Portre
nedir portre bir kişiyi farklı
yönleriyle tanıtmaya amaçlayan
yazılardır kişinin fiziksel görüntüsünü
aktarırsan Bu fiziksel portre kişinin iş
dünyasına ruhsal dünyasını düşüncelerini
aktarırsan da bu da ruhsal portre
olmaktadır ve son olarak da hal
tercümesi az önce de söylemiştim Osmanlı
döneminde yazılan daha çok özgeçmiş
özellik gösteren eserlerdir biz bu
eserlere hal tercümesi diyoruz ve burada
otobiyografide bitiriyoruz Şimdi nereye
geçeceğiz tezkireye arkadaşlar tezkire
tezkire nedir hemen bakalım Eski
dönemlerde yani Divan edebiyatında
sanatçıların hayatlarının anlatıldığı
eserlerinden örneklerin verildiği
metinlere Biz tezkire diyoruz
günümüzdeki biyografinin karşılığı
olarak da tezk
değerlendirebiliriz tezkerelerde
özellikle Divan şairlerin hayatlarına
eserlerine ve edebi özelliklerine yer
verilir gençler yani tanıda Bir şairin
hayatını aktarır onun şiirlerine yer
verir onun edebi özelliklerine de yer
verir Tabi bunu yaparken de öznel
davranır yani çok fazla nesneden
davranmamıştır sevdiği birisini
fazlalıkla övmüştür sevmediği birine
fazlaca yermiştir Bu nedenle teskereler
Bu anlamda kusur var ama her açıdan da
önemli Bunu unutmayalım Çünkü biz
tezkiler sayesinde Aslında atıyorum 16
yüzyıldaki şairleri yakından tanımam
fırsatını buluyoruz az önce de
söylediğim gibi testereler öznel bir
tutumla Övgü ve gergi amaçla kalemi
alınmıştır Ve bunu yaparken de Şair Bu
öznel düşüncelerini sana attığı bir
üslupla dile getirmiştir Çünkü Divan
Edebiyatı ise söz konusu biliyorsunuz ki
divan edebiyatının ne vardı süs vardı
sanat vardı abartı vardı Her şey vardı
yani Amaç zaten bir şey yazmak değil
amaç bu şeyi süslü Sanatlı bir şekilde
yazıyor aktarabilmek bu test tam olarak
karşımıza çıkmış Bizim edebiyatımızda
test girenin ilk örneğini veren isim Ali
Şir nevaid'dir onun yazmış olduğu mecâ-i
asla unutmuyorsun Bunun dışında Anadolu
sahasında yazılan ilk eserimiz ise sav
Bey'in yazmış olduğu hash5 adlı eserdir
Tabii ki tezkire alanında yani Türk
edebiyatındaki ilk tezkire
Anadolu'da yazılan ilk test kule ise
hashta bunu unutmuyoruz ve burada birkaç
önemli tezkireye isim olarak değinelim
mesela Latif bir tezkeresi latifi
tarafından yazılmıştır meşarı Şuara O da
aşık Çelebi tarafından yazılmış
Gülşen'in Şuara ise ahdi tarafından
yazılmış yine bir başka meşhur testere
olan kınalizade tezkeresi de Kınalıada
Hasan Çelebi tarafından yazılmış bu
eserlerde ama aklımızda bulunsun bitti
mi Hayır şimdi bir de test kitlelerin
bölümlere bakacağım teskereler üç farklı
bölümden oluşur bunların birincisi
mukaddimedir burada bir giriş yapılır
eserin yazılma Sebeb bahsedilir ve aynı
zamanda eser kime sunulduysa o kişi
hakkında da övgüler yer alır ikinci
bölüm asıl metindir yani şairler
hakkında bilginin verildiği bölümdür
burada şairlerin hayatından edebi
özelliklerinden bahsedilir ve son bölüm
ise hatimedir burada eserin yazılışı
hakkında bilgiler verilir ve dualar
edilerek tezkireler bitirilir diyorum
böylelikle bu videoda biyografi
otobiyografi ve tezkiri ele aldık böyle
bir video oldu Umarım sizler için
fazlasıyla faydalı olacaktır hem
derslerde hem de sınavda Eğer videomuzu
Beğendiyseniz Ne yapıyorsunuz gerçekten
beğeni butonuna basıyorsunuz sonra
kanala abone oluyorsunuz ve
düşüncelerinizi Olumlu ya da olumsuz
fark etmez benimle paylaşıyorsunuz
Sizden gelecek her türlü düşünceye
yoruma ihtiyacım var Bir sonraki videoda
Bir sonraki derste tekrar görüşürüz
Şimdi Kendine iyi bak hoşça kal sevgiler